the health secretary calls their pay
demands unrealistic but Junior doctors
say it's simply what they're worth four
days of strikes will go ahead on Tuesday
unless the government present what
unions call a credible offer I apologize
to anyone that has any appointments uh
canceled we're already missing Cancer
Care deadlines because we don't have
enough staff to to see these patients in
a timely manner and helping to restore
our pay so not a pay rise just to
restore our pay is is one of the main
ways that we can do this
there are around 75 000 Junior doctors
in NHS England but what do they do well
the majority of Junior doctors aren't
actually that Junior they're all
qualified who could then spend up to
eight years practicing while in clinical
training before reaching consultant
level and they make up nearly half the
medical Workforce pay can range from
just over 29 000 pounds to 58 000 pounds
a year with the average around 55 000.
the British Medical Association which
represents doctors is asking for a pay
rise of 35 but in the Sunday Telegraph
the health secretary says the bma's
demands are out of step with pay
settlements in other parts of the public
sector Steve Barkley writes it seems
they meaning the BMA are intent on
maintaining a militant stance rather
than working with the government and NHS
management to meet the best interests of
their members and of patience
NHS leaders say these strikes will bring
the worst disruption yet the four days
of industrial action that we will see
this week will be the longest period
we've had of any of the strikes this
winter and of course it's coming after a
four-day bank holiday weekend uh so I'm
absolutely certain that we will see a
higher level of disruption than we've
seen at any time this winter perhaps uh
at any time during NHS history
in fact it's estimated nearly 200 000
patients will see appointments
procedures even time-sensitive cancer
treatment delayed
access to the NHS is absolutely crucial
because inevitably as we get older we
tend to pick up more health problems so
when there's any kind of question mark
about your capacity to access that that
is undoubted the body concern for older
people doctors say if patients haven't
been contacted by now they should just
turn up as usual but it's certainly far
from business as usual for Health
Service stricken by strikes mired in
dispute
Sky News